hi there steve kaufman here
um today i'm going to talk about
active and passive vocabulary in fact i
call it in praise of passive vocabulary
you know i often have comments uh people
telling me that uh
in order to learn a word they have to
use the book if they don't use it they
can't learn it
and of course many people say how do i
convert my
passive vocabulary into active
vocabulary
um
let's begin with the first suggestion
that in order to learn a word you have
to use it
i
do not believe that
it is not possible
um in the case of my russian studies
i can read tolstoy
my
link statistics tell me that i know
50 000 words in russian now russian is
an inflected language so
maybe
if i compare that to english it equates
to 30 000 words and if i look at word
families whatever it is maybe it's 20
000 words
15 it doesn't matter
the point is that i have rarely spoken
in russia
over the three years that i've been
studying russian
i've had maybe 15 or 20 conversations in
russian
half an hour long 15 minutes long not
much longer
and when i speak i use very few words
when i speak i'm in survival mode i'm
reaching for words
and
gradually the words that i can use
uh you know the number of words that i
can use increases as i
for whatever reason suddenly remember
something that i heard
but my learning of words comes from what
i listen
to and what i read it can be the only
source of new words
and
the number of words that i know
passively far exceeds the number of
words that i can use
actively and i'm happy
with that because in my situation
my main objective is to understand i
want to understand
books and audio books and radio programs
and podcasts and movies and if i can
understand i'm happy
because i'm not in a situation where i
need to use the language every day
now if i were in a situation where i was
using the language more often i would
have more active words in other words i
would be constantly
seeking searching trying to get at the
words that i have learned passively and
start to use them but still i would have
a limited number of words that enabled
me to get through the situations that i
would come across whether it be at work
or in stores or in social conversation
with friends
now we know that in normal conversation
that in the case of english the leading
they are the most frequent 1 000 or
let's take 2 000 words are going to
account for
90 of a conversation but they may only
account for 70 or 75
of a academic document
so
uh
for conversation you don't need as many
words
but the main thing is that you
understand what the other person is
saying in a conversation
and and of course we know very well that
to say that 90
of the words accounts or at least the
most frequent words accounts for 90 of
the conversation doesn't help you if the
person keeps on referring to things that
you don't understand so it is far more
important to be able to understand what
other people are saying
and if as you try to express yourself
you're missing some words and you ask
how do you say that
people will help you so
if you speak more and if you have more
opportunity to use the words your pas
your your passive words will be
converted to active words but they start
as passive words and they remain passive
words for a long time and your
understanding of these words
increases as you encounter them in
different contexts
and eventually you're able to convert
some of them into active words but it's
not a big deal it is normal i would
imagine that the ratio in a when you're
in a foreign language of
passive to active words is ten to one or
i don't know what the number is but
vastly greater and there's nothing wrong
that's good now how do you increase the
number of active words words that you
can use yeah try to use them
it's one way if you are in situations
where you have to speak but if you're
not often in situations where you have
to speak
don't worry about it you're fine
language is not about performing for a
grade for a mark for a test
language is about communicating so if
your communication needs are largely to
understand things then you should be
working very hard on increasing your
passive vocabulary and it's also easier
to increase your passive vocabulary by
continuing to read and listen
and you know increasing your
understanding your grip on these words
until they will slowly slide into
the active ledger but there will always
be a much smaller number of them
furthermore
we will always make mistakes we will
always struggle for words
in a foreign language
why do people expect that they're going
to perform somehow perfectly in a
foreign language you aren't going to
so i say passive vocabulary is great the
more of it you have the greater the
potential for you to convert some of
those passive words into active words
and
uh the different things that you can do
like reviewing them in flashcards to
become more attentive
that all helps
obviously talking helps to be able to
use them you've got to use them
i i'm not a great fan of correcting
people when they speak and that's why at
least when we have our online
conversations we try not to correct
while people are speaking but we type
out all the words and phrases that they
misuse
and we send them a report which they
then can study so you have the time at
your leisure to study these and slowly
slowly and you will also as with
everything in language you'll just be
able to use certain words at times then
you'll forget certain words at times so
again don't expect perfection when
you're working on a second language but
passive vocabulary is great and it'll
gradually convert itself into active
vocabulary
as you as you use them
so i guess that was uh that was the main
thing on this uh what was the other one
they said
um yeah so i don't believe that you have
to use a word in order to remember it
but you do have to use it in order for
it to be active if you haven't used it
it's not active
uh but you can build up the potential
for active
vocabulary by continuing to expand your
passive vocabulary
there we go
thank you very much i hope this makes
sense